[Applaus]
[Musik]
willkommen liebe zuschauer history live
dem historischen quartett aus sonics der
kalte krieg ist ja geschichte darf noch
immer geistert ein gespenst umher
vor allem in europa vor allem jetzt in
diesen tagen wo die angst vor einem
neuen kalten krieg herumgeht hohe zeit
also zu fragen was am kalten krieges war
etwas legende darüber diskutieren wir
heute mit dem historiker bernd kleiner
dem ehemaligen us-botschafter in
deutschland john kornblum und der
journalistinnen und historikerin
gabriele krone schmalz
er konnte um war der kalte krieg
eigentlich zwangsläufig die beiden
siegermächte waren ja noch knapp so war
zuvor aus verbündet gegen hitler
der kalte krieg war wahrscheinlich die
logische folge von dem mann wird nicht
nur von dem zweiten weltkrieg sondern
auch für den kollaps des europäischen
staaten systems nach 1914 und die
sowjetunion hatte es eher geplant als
die vereinigten staaten die für einen
staaten waren bereit nach hause zu gehen
wirst du berliner blockade und aber für
die union was aus meiner sicht logisch
die wollten den westen
wir wollen in deutschland zu weit von
der grenze wie möglich halten und die
haben das sozusagen ein cordon sanitaire
errichten wollen
das war viel zu schwierig für sie und
über die jahren war sehr kompliziert
geworden aber die logik war er da und es
soll hätte niemanden überraschen sollen
dass es gekommen ist
manche historiker behaupten ja dass der
kalte krieg zumindest in europa trotz
aller spannungen eben nicht auf
schlachtfeldern stattgefunden habe
sondern vor allem in den köpfen der
menschen gleichsam als imaginärer
konflikt können sie das nachvollziehen
hat rainer ja einerseits schon
es war ja eine auseinandersetzung die
tag für tag jahr für jahr begleitet war
von der vorstellung ist könnte zu einer
eskalation
zwischen den supermächten kommen zu
einem nuklearen schlagabtausch
die vorstellung die vision eines alles
vernichtenden krieges war sozusagen ein
steinerner gast
darüber hinaus haben sich die
protagonisten in ost und west ja auch so
benommen als wären sie in einem realen
krieg man hat uns um verpulvert für
aufrüstung und gesellschaftlichen
ressourcen mobilisiert aus allen
bereichen
man hat entsprechende propaganda gemacht
trotzdem beliebt dieser krieg wie wir
alle wissen zum glück auf der nördlichen
halbkugel kalt aber von einem imaginären
krieg kann man auf der südlichen
halbkugel überhaupt nicht da gab's
stellvertreterkriege gab
stellvertreterkriege einige historiker
gehen so weit zu sagen es war 150 an der
zahl nicht alle durch den kalten krieg
ausgelöst
aber in seinem windschatten organisiert
und durchgeführt mit 22 millionen toten
das nie verloren noch als imaginäre
stichwort propagandakrieg da waren ja
gut und böse in diesem krieg der
weltmächte gängige begriffe war das
ballyhoo oder steckt da auch ernst
dahinter rücken hat ja mal gesagt
udssr reich des bösen für die sowie zwei
recken der böse kalte krieger die
ernsthaft war dass das war die
klassische denkweise im kalten krieg auf
der einen seite sitzen die guten auf der
anderen seite sitzen die bösen das habe
ich in der schule auch noch so
mitbekommen und dann meinen zu damaliger
zeit noch nicht so furchtbar viel
voneinander wusste wie man heute wissen
kann durch entsprechende mittel auch
weil man darauf angewiesen sich in
vorstellungen zu ergehen und wenn sich
beide seiten voneinander bedroht fühlen
was der fall war
dann treibt das blüten und dann haben
wir das bekommen was wir ja auch als
gleichgewicht des schreckens bezeichnen
was aus meiner sicht nur mit viel glück
kalt geblieben ist denn es hat viele
situationen gegeben die man erst im
nachhinein als solche identifizieren
konnte dass sie hochgradig gefährlich
waren und wir sind immer so haarscharf
dran vorbei geschrammt
über diese situation wollen wir reden
die erste schlacht des kalten krieges
war ja die berliner luftbrücke 48 49 war
das damals schon am rande eines heißen
kriegs rainer das glaube ich nicht
stalin hat er ist auf eine machtprobe
ankommen lassen
und er wollte meines erachtens vor allen
dingen den usa die grenzen ihrer macht
zeigen
er wollte ihnen signalisieren ihr seid
zwar im alleinbesitz der atombombe aber
diese atombombe nutzt euch rein gar
nichts
ich habe als früherer der sowjetunion in
berlin den strategischen den
geostrategischen vorteile auf meiner
seite
wenn er es zum äußersten hätte kommen
lassen wollen dann hätte er auch die
luftkorridore blocher blockiert dann in
der tat wäre es eine kriegs trächtige
situation gewesen aber so war es ein
spiel um macht und einfluss um
symbolische politik dass dann der westen
gewonnen hat wie wir alle wissen aber es
war noch nicht diese kriegs trächtige
situation wie wir sie beispielsweise aus
korea oder insbesondere aus der
kubakrise oder vom märz und vom november
1983 kennen darüber wollen wir noch
reden aber vorher gab es im oktober ein
60 beispielsweise zwei monate nach dem
berliner mauer war am checkpoint charlie
eine situation wo sich russische und
amerikanische panzer direkt
gegenüberstanden war das eine ernsthafte
brenzlige situation der gründung nicht
brenzlig
das ist kein krieg hätte geben können es
war aber sehr wichtig gerade für den
westen weil wir wollten sicherstellen
dass der zugang für den westen nach
ostberlin offen blieb und man war bereit
auch eine konfrontation zu haben
die sache ist wie wir jetzt wissen ins
später auch durch einen telefonanruf
zwischen kennedy und kunststoff gelöst
worden und es war es war ein sehr
wichtiger zeitpunkt wahl von dann an
wenn charlie offen und von da an blieb
berlin eine stadt aber als gefahr von
einem krieg hat es eigentlich nicht
gegeben
aber ein jahr später kam ja dann die
kubakrise als
stoff raketen auf der zuckerinsel
stationierten als er sie wieder abzog
wurde öffentlich vermittelt dass die usa
den sieg davon getragen hätten und
stimmte das stimmt so dass das ist wie
so oft auch heute eine frage der
perspektive
wenn man die chronologie betrachtet
waren ja zunächst mal stationierung von
amerikanischen raketen in der türkei
dann gab es die stationierung der
russischen der sowjetischen raketen auf
kuba und dann dieser machtkampf diese
diese wirklich extrem gefährliche
konfrontationen und wenn man den belägen
glauben darf
die ich versucht habe zu finden und
gelesen habe dann war es nicht kennedy
der nach gegeben hat sondern gross chef
der nachgegeben hat also vielleicht
hilft uns das auch für heute dass man
die situation mal auflistet russland
durchaus zugänglich war
um eine sehr dramatische situation zu
entschärfen
darüber werden wir noch reden aber
damals gab es ja die angst wenn kennedy
in kuba einmarschiert überlegungen gab
es ja dann würde chruschtschow eventuell
west berlin erobern wäre ein solches
szenario wirklich nur konventionell
geblieben ohne atomwaffen
das hat man damals befürchtet aber die
quellen die uns mittlerweile zur
verfügung stehen insbesondere von
sowjetischer seite dokumentieren ganz
klar dass chruschtschow nicht im traum
daran gedacht hat berlin als preis für
kupfer zu nehmen er hat einigen
untergeordneten und mitarbeitern die
etwas derartiges in die diskussion
gebracht haben eindeutig signalisiert er
wolle davon nichts hören und am ende war
der ausgang dieser kuba-krise sieg der
vernunft aber nächsten sieg der ein oder
anderen seite sondern ein sieg der
vernunft microsoft auf die bremse
getreten ist wissend dass eben die
kontrolle über die ereignisse entgleitet
im grunde genommen kann man nicht sagen
haben wir in den zeiten des kalten
krieges extremes glück gehabt dass es so
jemand gab wie christoph der so reagiert
hat wieder reagiert hat und das zu
zeiten regens sowjetunion reich des
bösen
so jemand wie gorbatschow da saß der
auch na ja ebenso war und so agiert hat
wie er agiert hat das hätte ja auch
anders sein können oder bleiben sie
erstmal noch in den 60er jahren wie ihre
deutsche waren ja damals und auch später
gleichsam an der nahtstelle der blöcke
geteiltes land an der nahtstelle der
blöcke wenn wir die ersten opfer gewesen
das erste schlachtfeld mit sicherheit
das ist aus allen planspielen die wir
kennen aus allen militärübungen bekannt
und nicht umsonst hat helmut schmidt mal
in einer laune und wenn er es mit
cremiger zu tun hatte waren oft übel
gelaunt dem amerikanischen präsidenten
signalisierte präsident gehen sie davon
aus sollte es soweit kommen sollte die
abschreckung in zentraleuropa versagen
dann ist die bundeswehr die erste die
binnen 24 stunden kapituliert nicht weil
wir es müssen sondern weil wir es wollen
wissen dass wir das nicht verteidigen
können wozu ihr zu verteidigen
angetreten sind ja er kommt wäre das das
szenario gewesen wenn es zu einem krieg
gekommen wäre
helmut schmidt über haben ich weiß nicht
was herr schmidt gesagt hat aber die die
nato da habe ich viele jahre mit genau
mit diesem thema nichts gebracht die
nato war so ineinander verwebt sozusagen
das die frage ob die bundeswehr der
erste zu komponieren gewesen wäre
überhaupt nicht gestellt werden würde
weil die die pläne die man hatte die
waren alle defensiv plänen erstens muss
man sehr klar stellen die pläne die man
hatten passierten sich auf ein angriff
der sowie den oder warschauer pakt und
die mit eskalation
die farmer nicht so sehr ob truppen
gekämpft hätten die truppen hätten
gekämpft die frage wie möglich die
sogenannte nukleare option
und da war es ganz klar dass wenn es so
weit gekommen wäre wäre
der schlaf fällt natürlich deutschland
gewesen ohne frage und ich kann ihnen
berichten aus viele übungen wo ich
teilgenommen habe in der nato über
mehreren jahren und die wurden natürlich
so gemacht so dass man die klare option
benutzen musste dann haben die deutschen
vertreter immer gestoppt sie haben
gesagt wir können nicht weiter gehen
denn ich war einmal da war es für ping
zu einem eklat gekommen ist bei der der
generalsekretär der deutsche war er
sagte dass es nur ein kriegsspiel das
ist nicht echt
aber die deutschen vertreter bei uns
sagen auch in einem spiel wo wir
klarstellen dass wir das nicht zustimmen
würden so ist war der kalte krieg war
ein krieg um deutschland und das hat die
deutsche psychologie das ist so eine
politik der russen gegenüber im moment
in deutschland gibt hat auch mit diesem
kleinen krieg zu tun aber wenn vertreter
in einem solchen krieg spiel irgendwann
mal gesagt hätten oder haben stoppt dann
hätte es die bundesregierung doch dann
wohl auch in einem realen konflikt er
getan werden die sowjetischen panzer
durch die fulda gap oder durch die
norddeutsche tiefebene nach westen die
frage wäre zum beispiel sie wissen dass
bestimmt bis ende der achtziger jahren
waren grundstückspreise auf dem
östlichen seite des rheins in bonn
billiger als auf dem westlichen seite
ich meine man und es war nicht sein kann
wissen auch in köln
es war so nah und die tatsache ist als
wenn das passiert wäre was das
glücklicherweise nicht passiert ist dann
wären die so wie jetzt so schnell an den
rhein gewesen dass wir kaum chancen
gehabt habe zu fragen wer hat gekämpft
werden nicht gekämpft nicht weil wir
nicht genug trocken da hatten wir hatten
viele truppen aber die tatsache dass
überhaupt zu organisieren wenn sie jetzt
an richtigen andersrum die sowjets
hatten viele truppen die haben aber auch
andere alliierte truppen und vor allem
ddr truppen die branche auch nicht
gekämpft hätten
es war eigentlich eine schein
vorstellung es wäre nie dass so weit
gekommen wahrscheinlich war jener seite
wusste dass es nicht dass sein würde was
was geübt wurde
ab welchem zeitpunkt hätte die nato
taktischer art
um waffen eingesetzt ja das kann ich
sagen natürlich dass es die haben damals
in diesen in diesen übungen ganz
komplizierte szenarien geschrieben
sodass sie stufen stufen stufe null
aufgehen könnte man man man kann nicht
sagen wann oder über ob man hatte schon
klar war dass das ist ja genau die
pointe wenn sie militärische
organisation in diesem umfang
organisieren wird es während des kalten
krieges der fall war
dann können sie sich von der idee der
jederzeitigen politischen kontrolle
verabschieden
john f kennedy hat mal gesagt ich kann
anordnen was ich will
es wird immer irgendeinen idioten geben
am ende der befehlskette hat er nicht
mitbekommen hat was wir wollen
da kann der so viele unvorhersehbare
unwägbarkeiten ergeben dass die
vorstellung einer politischen
feinsteuerung ins reich der fabel zu
verweisen ist
ich glaube es war ziemlich rundum tolle
aber dann im kriegsfall meine ich neue
pixar ist versandt habe ich glaube nicht
dass die ein oder andere seite so weit
gebracht hätten
nach dem krieg waren aber es war doch
schon mal kommt es gab ja zwei
situationen sie haben eben 1983 erwählt
september 83 war es ja durch ein
missverständnis fast so einer atomaren
eskalation gekommen die sowjetische früh
waren zentrale hatte den staat
amerikanische raketen gemeldet und es
war ja wie man heute weiß doch die
besonnenheit eines einzelnen ein
gewisser stanislav petrov die das
schlimmste verhindert also es gab
situationen gab situation auch in dem in
dem manöver ebel archer im november drei
und ab zwei monate später ganz genau wo
man in der sowjetunion fuhren davon
ausgingen dass es ein dass ein angriff
bevorstünde
und dass diese dinge glimpflich
ausgegangen sind sind haben wir glücks
glücklichen umständen zu verdanken sie
wir haben gerade denjenigen angesprochen
der das nicht sofort nach oben gemeldet
hat dass es zu entsprechenden reaktionen
gekommen wäre
es hat andere dinge gegeben die dann so
waren zufällig dass nichts passiert ist
ich weiß das natürlich nicht aber ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass eine der
beiden seiten ernsthaft so etwas auch in
erwägung gezogen hätte
nur das scheint mir auch gar nicht die
große gefahr zu sein sondern dass etwas
passiert weil irgendjemand nicht so zu
erreichen ist weil missverständnisse in
dieser aufgeheizten atmosphäre des
gegenseitigen misstrauens dazu führen
dass man eben denkt bevor der muss ich
das ist die gefahr war die atmosphäre
anfang der 80er jahre nach einer relativ
ruhigen war also in den 70ern derartig
aufgeheizt weil auf der amerikanischen
seite präsident reagan start und auf der
sowjetischen seite zeitweise
generalsekretär an drobny
das hat damit zu tun vor allen dingen
hat es hat nichts damit zu tun dass sich
in dieser zeit ein enormes misstrauen
aufgebaut hat auf beiden seiten und das
ist charakter ist will unbedingt nun aus
der perspektive moskaus hat man für bare
münze genommen dass in den usa über
begrenzt bahre atomkrise diskutiert
worden ist völlig abgehobene debatten in
politischen zeitschriften in moskau ist
das so angekommen dass diese zeitung
politisch gesteuert von sich das ist
eine option auf das man hat im grunde
genommen die eigenen erfahrungen
übersetzt auf die usa nicht wissend dass
dort niemand im traum daran gedacht hat
diese gedankenspiele auch zu realisieren
aber die generation von antrieb auf die
den zweiten weltkrieg und den überfall
auf die udssr miterlebt hat hat damals
allen ernstes im internen kreis über ein
nukleares barbarossa geredet das ist
natürlich blödsinn gewesen das ist eine
reine fantasie aber im kalten krieg
beobachten wir oft wie fantasien und
imagination und ängste handlungsleitend
werden ob die content sind oder nicht
die begründet sind begründbar sind
spielt in dem punkt überhaupt keine
rolle es kommt auch die perzeption an
ich glaube eines darf man auch nicht
vergessen regen hat ja angefangen mit
sdi mit diesem raketenabwehrsystem und
diese diese option sich nicht mehr
wehren zu können
er hat mit sicherheit auch eine rolle
gespielt was das gegenseitige misstrauen
betrifft sehen sie das anders ganz
anders das ist eher eine deutsche
version
wir dürfen nicht vergessen jimmy carter
wurde gewählt
ähnlich wie später barack obama er sagte
wir wollen diesen kleinen krieg denken
ändern
er wollte alle truppen aus korea
ausziehen er wollte die nuklearen waffen
aus europa aussehen
er wollte sogar ein stopp an
waffenexporten überhaupt welt haben
und wer hat zuerst darauf reagieren
helmut schmidt in seiner rede herbst
1977 habe gewarnt vor sowjetische
aufrüstung die berühmte ss 20
und ich war damals in der nato
mitteilung und er war ziemlich panik da
weil man glaubte die deutschen haben
gesehen dass wir nicht genug für die
verteidigung zu tun und da habe es
hektische diskussion in der nato und
zwischen den vereinigten staaten und
deutschland
und dann hatten wir tatsächlich entdeckt
nickig aber die hände waren dass es
diese neue sache gab die so genannte
kunst müsse die man bis jetzt wovon man
nicht gehört haben und selbst schnell
wurde zusammen gespielt diese
doppelbeschluss so dass die nato eine
strategie hatte um gegen diese sehr für
deutschland aus deutschland gesehen
gefährliche sowjetische aufrüstung was
entgegenzutreten weiter nach oder im
selben jahr 1970 haben die sowjetische
invasion von afghanistan
das sehr sehr gefährlich gesehen wurde
ich war in diesen jahren hier in berlin
und das war sehr interessant der
sowjetische botschafter in ost berlin
hat uns angerufen und hat gesagt ich
rede ja ziele unter anweisung aus moskau
jetzt werden in berlin nichts passieren
wir haben einen krieg in afghanistan es
wird für europa nichts bringen das war
natürlich auch
als wir den nato doppelbeschluss gemacht
haben so die tatsache ist jimmy page ist
teilweise abgewählt worden weil er von
den europäischen verbündeten kritisiert
wurde dass er zu schwach war und
ausreichen ins amt kam
im nachhinein von afghanistan und mit
menschen die tatsächlich auch
chemikalien für zu schwach gefunden hat
hat den finger einzeln über verschiedene
sand zu bringen aber die russen wussten
ganz genau was da los waren die russen
haben glatt zu diesem zeitpunkt ein
riesen propagandakampagne der macht in
westeuropa gegen den doppelbeschluss das
nachher in 283 oder diesen krisen
friedensbewegung geführt hat und die
tatsache dass die russen angst hatten
dass regen an krieg anfangen würden das
ist einfach nicht wahr die wussten ganz
genau was los war und wichtiger ist dass
die beiden seiten wie vielleicht in 48
eine kampagne gegen einander gemacht
haben wir haben ja den doppelbeschluss
gemacht die russen haben die
friedensbewegung finanzieren und das ist
dann dazu gekommen ist so zu einem
stillstand sozusagen das im endeffekt
ist das abkommen gegeben
die mittelstreckenraketen wurden auf
beiden seiten abgezogen
er ist iii war immer eine schimäre die
russen müssen das ist schon mehrere war
aber die im endeffekt und das hat
gorbatschow mir persönlich gesagt im
endeffekt war das problem nicht alle
diese sachen sondern es war der ölpreis
und kollaps der sowjetischen wirtschaft
und das war viel wichtiger als alle
diese nebensachen im kalten krieg nicht
zu stücken das spielt sicher auch eine
rolle dass ist ja wäre ja albern das
nicht zuzugeben aber ich glaube dass zum
beispiel margaret thatcher nicht sehr
anfällig ist für russische oder
sowjetische propaganda und margaret
thatcher hat sich damals 83 wenn ich
nicht irre sehr massiv bei den
amerikanischen verbündeten zu wort
gemeldet und hat gesagt diese die in
zusammenhang mit diesem feature
manöver dass man doch vorsichtiger sein
sollte weil auf die art und weise etwas
ausgelöst werden könnte wofür wir alle
nicht sind ich meine es bleibt
festzuhalten wer jetzt was gewollt hat
oder nicht ist interessant zu
analysieren aber es bleibt festzuhalten
diese zeit des kalten krieges ist gut
gegangen weil zum richtigen zeitpunkt
die richtigen menschen nicht
durchgedreht sind sondern überlegte
entscheidungen getroffen haben oder es
kam erst gar nicht dazu dass man das
treffen musste nur besonders beruhigend
war das ja alles nicht und da denke ich
sollte man auch nicht wieder hin zurück
wollen ist es auch deshalb gut gegangen
herr greiner weil die pure existenz der
atombombe im kalten krieg den frieden
gesichert
nun er hat die pure existenz dieser
waffe hat mit sicherheit zu einer beiden
derzeitigen vorsicht beigetragen schon
in den 50er jahren aber erst recht nach
der kuba krise
was allerdings nicht ausschließt und das
war ja das verteufelte dieser waffen
dass man mit ihr auch immer gespielt hat
man hat die andere seite im ungewissen
gelassen wie weit man zu gehen bereit
ist
diese spielen mit ungewissheit gehört
zur strategie der abschreckung und das
hat allen möglichen fand das jeden
freien lauf gelassen und im november
1983 war es in der tat zu und da haben
wir eine differenz herkommt das auf
seiten des moskauer politbüros nicht nur
propaganda im spiel gewesen ist die
amerikanische botschaft in moskau hat
dem state department relativ schnell
danach signalisiert und dem
sicherheitsberater mcfarlane dass die
sorgen die antrieb auf umgetrieben haben
ernst zu nehmen sind und darauf hat
regen interessanterweise gesagt das kann
doch nicht sein dass die uns so
missverstehen und unsere absichten
derart verzerrt wahr nehmen
und er hat dann ab 19 84 früher 1984
eine ganz andere politik betrieben aber
teilweise basierend auf dieser nachricht
die nehmen das für bare münze
was bei uns einige die
intellect schulz in ihren blättern
vertrag verbreiten es war mehr als
propaganda das war der preis den man für
diesen kalten krieg und für die
abschreckungs logik immer wieder an
verschiedenen ecken gezahlt aber es gab
es gab so viel veröffentlicht wurden und
die russen haben natürlich jedes jahr
wahrgenommen
aber die russen mussten ganz genau woran
sie waren sie haben genau zu diesem
zeitpunkt diesen riesigen propaganda
kampagne gegen den westen geführt
also man sollte das nicht zu dazu
detailliert machen es war eine
allgemeine stimmung
eine allgemeine stimmung dieser
herauskam dass die sowjets ende des 19
ende der siebziger jahren die
entspannungs politik ziemlich abgespeckt
haben
natürlich kam mit regen einige die fans
hinter lexus da die die nicht gerade
ausgewogen waren aber die lage war
sie dürfen nicht vergessen es gibt
dutzende von konnten es gab damals
dutzende von kontakte zwischen den
russen und amerikaner jeden tag ich habe
hier auch sehr viel an tagen wir haben
den nutzen hier ständig diskutiert in
berlin
jetzt waren nicht also da wirklich ein
riesen verständnis dadurch an den nato
doppelbeschluss erwähnt hat der den
nachrüstung rüstungskontrolle
trotz aller deutschen demonstranten 82
schließlich nicht doch dann zum
einlenken gorbatschows geführt und damit
letzten endes auch ja zum ende des
kalten krieges und zur deutschen
wiedervereinigung
also ich finde das schwierig zu
beurteilen weil im nachhinein kann man
sagen ja hat ja funktioniert aber die
frage ist eben wie groß war das risiko
und war es das wert im nachhinein hat es
funktioniert und da kann man nur sagen
die kombination aus drohung einerseits
und ankündigung von zusammenarbeit
andererseits hat in dem fall
funktioniert und da spielen auch noch
ein paar andere dinge eine rolle die
situation
die war in der sowjetunion ob man darauf
einging oder nicht also wirtschaftliche
gründe die sie angesprochen haben
aber ich bin nicht sicher ob diese diese
massive drohungen ob das ein beispiel
ist auch jetzt für heute also ob uns das
heute weiterhilft um in der situation in
der wir sind
zu einer vernünftigen lösung zu kommen
mit der alle seiten leben können
man kann das problem ja auch von einer
anderen zeit daran gehen und sagen
dieser kalte krieg wurde nicht beendet
durch aufrüstung durch militärische
drohungen oder durch
abrüstungsverhandlungen in der tat durch
ein neues denken ein neues denken dass
michael gorbatschow in erster linie
verkörpert ein keltisch welcher der
sowjetischen wirtschafts zu tun nein
aber man hätte man hätte diese ökonomie
herr kornblum auch ganz anders noch
managen können über jahrzehnte vor sich
hin wurst und wein der punkt war dass
michael gorbatschow anregung
interessanterweise aus dem westen kommen
aus den usa
und was im europäischen kontext olof
palme willy brandt egon bahr
überlegungen einer gemeinsamen
sicherheitsarchitektur eines gemeinsam
aufzubauenden europa aufgegriffen und in
politik übersetzt hat zu einem zeitpunkt
wo die udssr mit ökonomischen problemen
zu kämpfen hatte aber längst noch nicht
bankrott war und dieses neue denken hat
etwas bewegt es hat diesen eispanzer des
kalten krieges diese verkapselung in
militärischen sicherheitsdenken oder nur
militärischen sicherheitsdenken
aufgebrochen und ohne gorbatschow wäre
das in dieser form nicht passiert war
das nie von gorbatschow denn wenn er
gewusst hätte was dabei rauskommt das
ende seines staates hätte er es dann
auch gemacht also haben wir so es war
sicher in gewisser weise naiv denn und
davon bin ich fest überzeugt gorbatschow
wollte die sowjetunion reformieren er
wollte auch sehr viel mehr
selbstständigkeit zu lassen das alles
aber er hatte sicher nicht im sinn die
sowjetunion aufzulösen
das ganz sicher nicht das neue denken
wovon sie nicht so viel halten herr
kornblum die entscheidende qualität
dieses neuen denkens in der damaligen
sowjetunion dass sie überhaupt so etwas
geführt hat bestand darin dass es eben
in der führung der fall war gorbatschow
hat es vorgegeben und das ist aber in
der bevölkerung auch so was von
fruchtbaren boden fiel
das hat sich ja gegenseitig befruchtet
da war ja eine stimmung die mit der
konnte man ja politisch arbeiten
das war nicht von oben auf
und das war auch nicht nur von unten und
oben hat es keine aufgegriffen und das
war eine enorme chance und um auf den
begriff naiv noch mal zurückzukommen
gorbatschow hat nach all diesen dingen
sowjetunion aufgelöst etc
doch sehr nachdenklich ich sage mal
diplomatisch darüber gesprochen wie sehr
er sich auf dinge verlassen hat die dann
eben nicht schriftlich fixiert waren und
von denen dann hinterher niemand etwas
wissen wollte stichwort nato
osterweiterung zum beispiel ich habe ihn
gefragt ob er denn auch so gehandelt
hätte wenn er gewusst hätte was dabei
herauskommt auflösung seines landes und
zersplitterung der so werden er hat
gesagt die geschichte hat ihre eigenen
gesetze
niemand kann sie aufhalten klingt ein
bisschen resignativ als in berlin die
mauer fiel hat der amerikanische autor
burton times gesagt wir haben den
verdammten kalten krieg gewonnen
war das nun individueller seufzer oder
auch so ein allgemeines grundgefühl im
westen dass der begriff triumphalismus
ist nicht meine aber der fällt mir dazu
ein
es war so ein überlegenheitsgefühl was
für meine begriffe von anfang an habe
ich das auch immer gesagt sehr sehr
kontraproduktiv war
denn nach meiner einschätzung ist ein
kalter krieg wirklich nur dann vorbei
wenn sich beide seiten zumindest als
gewinner fühlen dürfen sie glauben
wehrlein aus der kalte krieg noch
anderer de facto irgendwie so weit würde
ich vielleicht nicht gehen wobei die
situation heute ist nun wieder ganz
kompliziert aber in der situation damals
als die mauer fiel als die deutsche
vereinigung kam dann sich hinzustellen
und zu sagen wir haben den kalten krieg
gewonnen was sollte das denn bedeuten
hätte man das nicht irgendwie ein
bisschen ein bisschen anders formulieren
und auch ein bisschen an das zelebrieren
können
nein das ist schon richtig aber es ist
in der in der allgemeinen politischen
und auch medialen aufarbeitung durchaus
so angekommen
tut mir leid und dass die leute sich
erfreut
ja die leute sich gefreut haben was wir
davon haben ist ein demokratisches
europa bis das russische
dass die leute sich die freund habe
gerade in der ddr in poland in osteuropa
sollte selbstverständlich sein
sie sind nicht alle politologen das sind
menschen die unter den schlimmsten
schlimmsten unterdrücken gelebt haben
und die haben das denn für gefeiert dann
scheint mir so selbstverständlich zu
sein da sie weiß nicht warum wir das
überhaupt diskutieren die freien ist
eine andere geschichte feiern und sich
über die situation freuen und über die
öffnung freuen und über die chance die
es den menschen gibt auch demokratische
systeme zu etablieren
das ist was anderes als dass sie einige
sache die andere sache ist die und die
finde ich eben persönlich nicht
hilfreich für mich ist intelligente
politik wenn man auch auf die folgen
schaut die das haben kann und das war
mit sicherheit nicht intelligent sich
als sieger zu gerieren und wenn man sich
dreimal so gefühlt hat sie leben in
einer anderen welt das ist eine realität
dass man nach einem solchen langen zeit
sie feiert sich freute und auch das
gewisse regierungsmitglieder gesagt
haben wir haben gewonnen waren wir auch
gewonnen haben immer gesagt dass das ist
eine eine selbstkontrolle die normale
menschen nicht haben und dass daher die
frage ist was passiert nach her und ich
war eine etwa der führende amerikanische
und vermittler für den die ganzen daran
smarts mit den russen nachher mit
russland rat und das als sie war die
ganze zeit dabei wenn ich kann ihnen
sagen die russen mit dem wir damals
behandelt haben
die haben gesagt sie haben uns befreit
wir haben nichts von siegesstimmung des
westens gesagt sondern die waren
glücklich dass sie mit uns zusammen
verhandeln können und es war eine ganz
andere stimmung als da wie sie das
darstellen eine ganze sieg war die ganze
zeit dabei drei jahre lang das mag ja
alles sein dass man in einer situation
diese gefühle nicht unterdrücken kann
dass man sich freut ja dass man sich
auseinandersetzen auch eine regelung
finden hat es ist aber etwas ganz
anderes wie ich danach politik betreibe
und das ist aufgabe einer politischen
führung denjenigen über den ich
vermeintlich regierung fehlt habe nicht
zu behandeln
wie einen unterlegenen nein wie die eben
nach wie vor auf augenhöhe respektvoll
außenpolitik und sicherheitspolitik zu
bleiben da ist davos ist der westen und
ich sage das bewusst pauschalisierend
der westen in eine falle getappt man hat
geglaubt dieser vermeintliche sieg im
kalten krieg gibt uns alle möglichkeiten
der welt ohne rücksicht auf den
ehemaligen konkurrenten eine neue
weltordnung aufzubauen das war ein
intellektueller fehlschlüssen ohne die
auch intern von spitzenpolitikern wie
häufig genscher oder egon bahr im
nachhinein sehr sehr kritisch bewertet
worden ist mit dem satz wir haben uns in
dieser situation aus dem
koordinatensystem des kalten kriegs
leider nicht lösen können hätten wir das
gemacht werden wir zu einer belastbaren
und perspektivisch nur aus älteren
politik in der lage gewesen aber wir
haben uns immer noch eingekesselt in
dieses freund-feind-denken respektive in
dem fall in die vorstellung wir haben
gewonnen die sowjetunion ist konkurs
gegangen warum sollen wir uns noch
weiter um einen nachbarschaft auf
augenhöhe mit der kein wort davon dass
war dabei war leiter der europaabteilung
im state department in diesen jahren
durch hat das alles mit behandelt
erstens das hauptziel des westens und es
ist ein ziel bis heute uns freuen
sollten war die demokratie in osteuropa
zu befestigen
das war unser ziel sie haben recht wir
haben nicht gedacht was passiert mit
russland für uns waren die leute die 45
jahre lang unter dort wurden kann
russland wichtiger und wir haben die
fundamente auch durch die erweiterung
der nato und der eu für eine
demokratische entwicklung in diesem
starten das war viel wichtiger als alles
andere
aber zweitens und da war ich wirklich
eine der maßgeblichen menschen
wir haben da eine ganze strategie
ausgearbeitet um den russen
klarzustellen dass das kein sieg war das
für sie integrieren wollten in einem
wir haben verschiedene arrangements der
verhandelte hand mit mit den
außenministern mit allen anderen
verhandelt das hat direkte kontakte
zwischen den präsidenten
es war alles andere als was sie denken
was passiert ist ist folgendes das wegen
auch schwierigkeiten innerhalb russland
vor allem wirtschaftliche
schwierigkeiten das zarte pflänzchen der
demokratie in russland
schwierigkeiten hatte bis heute aber das
war eigentlich hat sehr wenig mit dem
handeln des western zu tun und die die
legende dass wir versprochen haben dass
die nato nicht erwartet werden würde
kann keine kann nicht wahr sein weil
niemand zu diesem zeitpunkt daran
gedacht hatte die nadel zur erweiterung
die nadel zu erweiterungen zu erweitern
kann ein paar jahre später 67 95 96
staaten osteuropas knie fällig die hage
die carmen gebeten und der einer der
hauptakteure denn diese sache war der
deutsche verteidigungsminister der sagte
schau mal was hier passiert so die
können sagen was sie wollen aber ich war
dabei
jedenfalls was wir hier an haben es weiß
dass historiker problematische bemerkung
ich war dabei und ich weiß was wir
gesagt haben was wir getan haben
und die sagen dass wir irgendwie trip
triumphal gegen die russen es ist
einfach nicht wahr
vielleicht einen einen einsatz der uns
wieder auf eine andere ebene bringt wenn
sie so engagiert sagen das ist nicht
wahr das ist nicht wahr
dann möchte ich einfach ganz ruhig sagen
es gibt einen britischen philosophen der
heißt lobby stuart mill und der hat
gesagt und das finde ich sehr wichtig es
gibt mehr als eine wahrheit und deshalb
ist es wichtig darüber zu streiten und
das finde ich eine ebene wo man zu einer
lösung kommen kann ihre wahrheit ist die
ihre ist die unsere ist wieder eine
andere ich weiß am verschiedener karten
trotzdem verschieden es geht ja fakten
kann man in verträgen nachlesen
aber es gibt auch dinge die fakten sind
die mit wahrnehmungen zusammenhängen und
wahrnehmungen abzutun als etwas was
nicht existiert und politisch keine
rolle spielt halte ich nicht für
intelligent deswegen wenn man
dinge auf den tisch legt über die wir
jetzt gerade reden und schildert wie
sich die sowjetunion damals und russland
später behandelt gefühlt hat dann heißt
das nicht im umkehrschluss und da jetzt
gleich eine barriere vorzuschieben dann
heißt das nicht im umkehrschluss dass
moskau alles richtig gemacht hat
aber es heißt sehr wohl dass man die
wahrnehmungen die man in moskau hat im
westen ernst nehmen sollte damit man
westliche gute politik machen kann aber
das hat weh getan darum zu polemisieren
dass die nato osterweiterung als
strategischer fehler gewesen wäre
der punkt ist wie redet man mit dem
dritten im spiel in dem fall mit der
udssr wurde als mit russland
diesen vorgang zu zeitweiligen redet man
mit ihnen über diesen vorgang bietet man
ihnen ein sicherheitsmodell an eine
sicherheitsarchitektur die ihre
interessen mit einbezieht ohne
diejenigen osteuropas zu verletzt es gab
ja den nato russland rat in dieser phase
zwischen 590 1998 sind falls diesen
neuralgischen punkt betrifft gravierende
fehler gemacht worden
gravierende fehler gemacht worden unter
abwägung all dessen was man seit
gorbatschow und in der tradition von
willy brandt als gemeinsame
sicherheitspolitik diskutiert hat die
davon absieht dass man nur nationale
interessen zum massstab des handelns
macht das war das problem
natürlich gab es sich verhandlungen auf
unterschiedlichen ebenen das will ich ja
nicht in abrede stellen und dass sie mit
ihren zur werte oder russischen
gegenüber möglicherweise anders geredet
haben als diejenigen die auf höherer
ebene state department oder
gleich unter auf präsidenten ebene
diskutiert haben ist ja unbenommen
entscheidend ist dass irgendwann auf
seiten der syrischen führung wo es wegen
russischen führung wir reden über kalten
krieg da ist es immer das sowohl auf
seiten der russischen führung sich diese
idee eingenistet hat die nehmen uns
nicht ernst die behandeln uns als
konkursmasse die reden nicht auf
augenhöhe und warum ist das alles war da
erst ab heute in der zeit wurden jetzt
da das ja noch ganz anders sie ab 1996
ungeschlagen ist war es tut mir leid
kann ich frage die wir haben
unterschiedliche würfe darf ich auch was
sagen wir haben zuerst die fangen mit
den wichtigsten punkt die sicherung der
demokratie in mittel und osteuropa und
es stimmt wir hätten auch eine eine
ablehnung von den russen hingenommen war
wichtig war die sicherung der demokratie
und würde brauchen ja und nur heute zu
sehen was in der ukraine passiert was in
georgien passiert zu sehen wie wichtig
das ist dass die nato und die eu sowie
erweiterte punkt 1.2
wir wussten ganz genau dass wir die
sowjets nicht wie besiegten behandeln
müssen wir haben ganz komplizierte
sachen ausgaben nicht nur nato russland
hat sondern auch wirtschaftliche hilfe
die zahlen die die die höhe der
amerikanischen und deutschen
wirtschaftlichen hilfe für russland in
diesen jahren war den milliarden
drittens wir haben versucht die erhitzen
und die demokratie zu unterstützen wie
wir können das ist alles 8 notwendig das
können sie alles lesen sie deuten darauf
hin dass irgendwelche ganz oben
irgendjemand ganz böses gesagt hat in
diesem jahr war dass wir clinton wir
könnten war keine der irgendwie trial
gegen die russen daran gegangen das war
nicht regensburg hat ein problem aus
desinteresse schleifen lassen und
überlegt behandlung zu einer situation
hier wird nicht die für die zuständigen
russland zuständig dass russland einen
falschen weg genommen hat ist nicht die
verantwortung des westens wir haben da
wirklich unterpunkte funktion und puten
es hat
denn die große wirtschaftliche krise 98
gegeben
jetzt hat putin ausgesucht
wahrscheinlich so dass die er und seine
familie nicht ins gefängnis gegen
straffheit und dann putin hat gesehen
mit recht nebenbei gesagt dass russland
wieder stolz sein sollten
und er hat statt zu sagen was die jetzt
immer gesagt hat wir wollen partner und
teilen des westens eines gemeinsamen
europäischen hauses sein er hat gesagt
wir sind gegen den westen
und das ist dass das hat er schon 92
ich muss sagen die schiedsrichter
das ist die tatsache was passiert ist
natürlich ist dass die die zustände
innerhalb russlands katastrophale an
man kann den westen vielleicht
kritisieren dass man das nicht ganz
verstanden hat aber das wäre auch nicht
unsere rolle gewesen jetzt sozusagen zum
beispiel wie er die wirtschaft zu
privatisieren hatte dass er nicht alles
an verschiedenen freunden geben sollte
dass das das hätten wir sowieso nicht
kontrollieren können und die
wirtschaftliche krise 98 waren
riesengroß schlimme krise und es hat den
weg russlands wirklich geändert ohne
frage aber ich kann ihnen sagen der
westen hat wirklich versucht und gerade
hier die bundesregierung unter helmut
kohl hat wirklich versucht alles
mögliche zu machen so dass die russen
das ertragen könnten und dass das nicht
gut geworden ist es ist ist tragisch
aber man soll jetzt nicht sagen dass der
westen das irgendwie hätte besser machen
können ohne dass gravierende fehler das
ist ihr wort gemacht worden sind das
sind keine gravierenden fehler gemacht
das sind entwicklungen gekommen die wir
vielleicht nicht vorhergesehen haben und
die wir nicht kontrollieren könnten
er verbitte zwei dinge dazu sie haben
völlig zu recht von der enormen
wirtschaftshilfe gesprochen die von
westlichen ländern nach moskau
geschlossen werden dafür eine aber
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit war nicht
gefragt das werden wir jetzt nicht
ausführen können warum das so war
er hat auch
große das hat mich sehr geprägt er hat
gesagt solange ihr uns helft und wir
sind da unten seid ihr wunderbar zu uns
und nett zu uns und freundlich zu uns
aber wenn wir euch versuchen auf
augenhöhe zu begegnen dann werden wir
euch suspekt und eins das möchte ich
schon klarstellen wir haben unsere
wahrheiten
das lässt sich auch belegen putin hat in
seiner ersten amtszeit am laufenden band
signale richtung westen gesandt zweite
vorstellung im juni 2001 sogar das noch
ja ja der hat da stehende ovationen für
bekommen er hat und das möchte ich auch
mal betonen er hat zu der zeit in
russland dafür kämpfen müssen das war
nicht eine unumstrittene position sich
richtung westen zu orientieren
gut ich bin wirklich kein also ich hab
nix metern putin zu tun aber ich möchte
als journalist und als historiker
einfach mal die dinge auf den tisch
legen die immer unter den tisch fallen
er hat in seiner ersten amtszeit
wirklich schmerzhafte aktivitäten
angestoßen um eine zivilgesellschaft auf
die beine zu stellen
das wurde im westen entweder gar nicht
zur kenntnis genommen oder gleich mit
häme übergossen
das sind dinge die in der ersten
amtszeit gelaufen sind und wo die von
putin von putin da waren war auch sehr
autokratisch der elemente journalist
ermordet
politkowskaja das ist dann wieder eine
ganz andere geschichte
worum es mir geht meine güte dass man
wenn man im eigenen interesse handelt
und das interesse deutschlands europas
der usa und sicher auch das interesse
russlands ist frieden zu erhalten und
das leben der menschen so angenehm wie
möglich zu machen
und dann finde ich es absolut
kleinkariert sich dinge um die ohren zu
werfen die man erstens jetzt nicht mehr
ändern kann sondern man sollte sich
hinstellen und sagen wie kommen wir aus
dieser geschichte und zwar nicht auf
konfrontation das bringt nichts oder
dass man sie haben das stichwort
demokratie ich bin ein überzeugter
demokrat und versuche in meiner arbeit
alles zu tun um das zu unterstützen
aber es gibt gegenden in dieser welt da
ist demokratie nicht die priorität
sondern eine andere und wenn menschen in
dieser gegend diese priorität
artikulieren dann denke ich haben
auch die pflicht dass überhaupt mal
entgegen zu nehmen und damit umzugehen
und ihnen nicht etwas überstülpen zu
wollen was nicht funktioniert aus ganz
vielen gründen
ich bin sowieso der meinung wenn man
versucht beschleunigt also demokratische
entwicklungen zu beschleunigen von außen
dann steigt man nur die falschen leute
und gibt es beispiele haufenweise in der
welt also ein bisschen aber nun der der
lupenreine demokrat wladimir putin 2014
die krim angesagt ist das nicht einfach
eine provokation die gegen jeglichen
versuch von miteinander zu ändernder
stößt nun wenn man dieses beispiel nimmt
und die bisher das bisher gesagte rück
bindet auf die geschichte des kalten
krieges kommt man zu einem interessanten
ausgangspunkt was hat diesen kalten
krieg in wesentlichen befeuert es war
nicht fragen der handelsbilanz es war
nicht fragen von wirtschaftswissen es
war die wechselseitige wahrnehmung von
sicherheit oder unsicherheit und daraus
haben politiker ich komme gleich nochmal
zugriff darauf haben politiker wie willy
brandt olof palme richard nixon henry
kissinger die konsequenz gezogen dass
man in den beiderseitigen beziehungen
glock übergreifend entspannungs politik
konflikt moderation betreiben muss um
die sicherheitsinteressen der jeweils
anderen so ernst zu nehmen dass es nicht
zu diesen besagten und immer wieder
während des kalten krieges
dokumentierten kurzschlüssen kommt und
genau diese perspektive das primat einer
gemeinsamen sicherheitspolitik ich kann
mich nicht oft genug wiederholen an
diesem punkt ist in den jahren nach dem
ende des kalten krieges unter die räder
gekommen führende westliche politiker
haben vorgeschlagen entweder nato
aufzulösen und die ksc zu transformieren
in eine gemeinsame
sicherheitsarchitektur oder russland
einzuladen nato mitglied zu werden
das waren ernsthafte überlegung die
wesentlich relevanter gewesen sind als
wirtschaftsaustausch man hat und das war
mein punkt und das ist eine andere ebene
ist eine andere perspektive dass eine
historisch informierte perspektive die
den kalten krieg zurück bindet zu den
auseinandersetzungen heute man hat
dieses window of opportunity sie
schließen lassen das war das
hauptproblem und dann resultiert daraus
so etwas wie die annexion der crème der
westen die sonderaktionen der gräber mit
schulden und momentum moment moment
lassen sie uns bitte nicht die
koordinaten des kalten krieges an die
beurteilung dieser komplexen situation
heran ziehen nicht schuld und auf der
einen seite und unschuld auf der anderen
nicht schwarz und nicht war es so hat
auch der kalte krieg nicht funktioniert
es war ein wechselseitiges sich
hochschaukeln
ich verteidige nicht das was putin auf
der krim getan hat aber nehmen sie bitte
zur kenntnis dass auch in dem
assoziationsabkommen mit der ukraine
dass die eu geschlossen hat
formulierungen drin stehen wie wir
machen uns gedanken über gemeinsame
militärische kooperation dass so etwas
auf der seite von politikern die aus
welchen gründen auch immer geneigt sind
paranoiden vorstellungen oder
minderwertigkeitskomplexen anzuhängen
anders interpretiert werden als bei
politikern die aus dem bewusstsein ihrer
nationalen stärker agieren liegt auf der
hand
das war im übrigen auch genau den
sprengsatz der microsoft berlin krisen
mit befeuert hat der ihn ermutigt hat
aufkleber raketen zu stationieren diese
perspektive wir werden militärisch unter
druck gesetzt und können dem nur etwas
entgegen setzen indem wir selber aktiv
werden
das spielt bei der krim eine große rolle
das ist eine erklärung das ist keine
entschuldigung herr konnte aber eine
erklärung die wir aus historischer
perspektive ernst nehmen
sie hören deutsche stimmen der herr
kornblum sind das typische deutsche
stellen ziemlich ja das macht das das
hat noch nichts aber es wird ja
überhaupt nichts mit der realität zu tun
das ist das problem
grimm war wahrscheinlich und es gibt
endlose auch dokumentationen eine ein
versuch putins seine innenpolitische
lage zu stabilisieren
dieses abkommen das die eu wohl keine
angeboten hat war so was von niedrig
belangloses es war nur eine
absichtserklärung zur wirtschaftlichen
lage haben daneben sind und wie sich
attraktive das gegenüber in den blick
nicht nur das was man selber will ist
sondern auch das was aber gegenseite was
man selber getan hat wahrgenommen
handlung hat weiter das war es besser
mich noch mal unterbrochen werden würden
die tatsache ist keine möchte hin zu den
westen kommen die tatsache ist georgien
möchte ein teil des westens sein dass
das problem ist und das ist ein problem
nicht nur von heute von gestern auch
nichts seit dem kalten krieg ist ein
problem dass europa mit russland seit
300 jahren hat dass russland einen teil
von europa ist nicht oft nicht ernst
genommen wird von europa hat die polizei
aber auf der anderen seite eine
gesellschaft hat die immer gegen normen
in europa stößt und das gesagt eine
gegenreaktion das ist keine sache des
kalten krieges keine sache von den
letzten zehn jahren ist eine sache von
den letzten 300 jahren und europäische
politiker amerikaner haben kam eine
rolle hier gespielt haben teilweise gut
darauf reagiert teilweise sehr schlecht
darauf reagiert haben sie recht völlig
recht nur kommen wir wieder zunehmen
ende des kleinen krieges bewussten das
alles und das hauptziel war ich muss das
noch wieder beton scheint ihnen nicht so
wichtig zu sein
die demokratie in europa zu schützen und
beste bayerischen staaten auch in dem
rad in finnland zu schützen die sehr mit
großen fähigkeiten seine unabhängigkeit
bewahrt hat damit auch unsere
unterstützung
und wir haben unser bestes getan wenn
sie sagen dass das nicht gut genug war
es kann sein dass das stimmt aber es war
kein tripolis muss es war auch kein
versuch russland irgendwie klein zu
kriegen
es war ein versuch eine demokratische
offene juristische lage in europa
auszubauen und die sogenannten
nachbarschaftspolitik der eu war alles
andere als irgendwie eine militärische
bedrohung die eu hat nichts mit womit
sie bedrohen können es war ein versuch
diese ländern ein bisschen
wirtschaftliche unterstützung und ein
bisschen perspektive auf demokratie zu
tun
und wenn sie das schlecht finden dass
die eu eine demokratische perspektive
für die ukraine entwickeln wollen dann
sind würdig leben auf anderen planeten
aber sie machen entweder oder sogar gar
kein genauer gesagt nein es war uns ein
wir sollten jetzt aus einer gewissen
naivität herauskommen
die krim und das was da passiert ist hat
sicher nichts damit zu tun dass es nur
um das eu assoziierungsabkommen ging
wobei da auch eine menge militärisches
drin stand was die meisten
geflissentlich übersehen haben
sie haben gesagt die ukraine will in den
westen wenn sie sich die umfragen mal
anschauen auch gerade was
nato-mitgliedschaft angeht haben sie ja
heute noch keine mehrheit dafür aber das
ist eine andere geschichte könnte man
aber zum thema demokratie auch noch
anführen
was und jetzt versuche ich nochmal die
russische perspektive wenn bei jedem
nato gipfel seit 2008 immer wiederholt
wird die beitrittsperspektive für
georgien und für die ukraine
was glauben sie denn was da in moskau
passiert wenn man weiss aha die ukraine
jetzt das eu assoziierungsabkommen wo
vorher niemand mit moskau geredet hat
das wäre auch intelligent gewesen
das sage ganz viel so das wäre wirklich
gut gewesen hätten wir das alles hätten
wir die probleme die wir jetzt haben die
hätten wir nicht man hat die flotte auf
der krim die perspektive der ukraine
richtung nato was glauben sie denn was
man dann in moskau darüber denkt stellen
sich das doch mal praktisch vor also
man hätte darüber reden sollen man hätte
moskau von anfang an damit einbeziehen
müssen dann wäre es doch durchaus
denkbar gewesen solche beispiele gibt es
ja weltweit warum macht man nicht einen
speziellen status für die krim damit die
flotte da bleiben kann damit die
menschen sich unter internationaler
aufsicht dafür entscheiden können wofür
sie sich ohne entschieden haben
das sind alles gut aber hätte man machen
können und das lag ja auf der hand ist
war ja überhaupt kein zeitdruck da es
war ja nicht gewollt und das sind dinge
finde ich über die muss man reden dürfen
ohne dass man sagt das stimmt alles gar
nicht und wir machen ja nicht lauter
fehler
ich denke aber dass man wenn man auf so
einer situation raus möchte politisch
die ja wirklich katastrophal ist im
moment weil auch solche dinge wie
gesichtsverlust eine rolle spielen wenn
man daraus will dann muss man wenigstens
denke ich auch eine gewisse selbstkritik
bereit sein zu üben um auf dieser basis
dann lösungen zu finden wo die
interessen beider seiten berücksichtigt
werden wir tun doch jetzt die politik
kommt mir so vor dass die interessen des
westens legitim sind und alles was
russland als interesse vorbringt ist von
vornherein schon illegitim warum kann
man nicht sagen die haben interessen wir
haben interessen wir setzen uns zusammen
und machen eine ganz normale
verhandlungs- und jeder muss auf den
anderen zugehen und auch bereit sein was
abzugeben und nicht ihr wollt ja sowieso
nur imperial die ganze welt beherrschen
und man nimmt ziemlich ernst das ist
doch das wo man im moment darauf
herumreitet und wo man überhaupt nicht
weiterkommt die zeit ist so
vorangeschritten dass nun bereits die
zeit für meine letzte frage an sie alle
ist gorbatschow hat 20 14 gesagt beim 25
jahrestag des mauerfalls und das war
nach dem einmarsch auf die krim in der
lage sagt die welt steht am rande eines
neuen kalten krieges einige sagen er hat
bereits begonnen was ist zu tun um einen
neuen kalten krieg in europa zu
verhindern erinnert nun wir haben vorhin
über das engl
des kalten krieges geredet und über die
tatsache dass man außenpolitik nicht nur
mit dollars und waffen betreiben kann
und betreiben sollte sondern dass zu dem
ende des kalten krieges ein neues denken
entscheidend beigetragen hat ein denken
das die asymmetrie zwischen
militärischer sicherheit und mit
diplomatischen mitteln hergestellter
sicherheit ad acta legt das ist der
entscheidende punkt diese perspektive
die aus der entspannungs politik kommt
zum maßstab des gegenseitigen handels
der außenpolitik zu machen und in dem
sinne mit anderen früheren konkurrenten
als partner zu reden das ist mehr als
raketen und mehr als dollars
naja ein krise ist nicht geben weil er
keinen krieg ein historisches ereignis
war ob es große spannungen bis hin zu
gefährlichen spannungen mit russland
geben könnte steht auf der hand aber
dass die dass die lösung ist nicht jetzt
auf die sicherheits politischen
vorstellungen von herrn love zum
beispiel gehen er sagt dem wir sollen
unsere nachbarschaft kontrollieren sie
kontrollieren ireland
das können wir nicht machen was wir
machen müssen ist oft mit den russen
reden und sah ihn sagen wo die grenzen
sind und sagen wo wir was zu tun haben
aber kalte krieg wird es nicht geben das
wäre aber eine zeit die spannungen geben
franz schmalz ich halte es für sehr
gefährlich
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen ergreifen
wo immer sie sich bieten und nicht so
angesprochen reagieren denn herr trump
mit herrn putin versucht eine lösung zu
finden
denn ich möchte da nichts weiter sagen
aber in einem hat er recht dass ein
gutes verhältnis zu russland im
interesse amerikas nicht ohne schmalz
meine haaren herzlichen dank wenn der
kalte krieg in einen heißen umgeschlagen
wäre dann werden wir deutsche an der
nahtstelle der glocke die ersten opfer
gewesen und die ersten täter und wir
hätten aufeinander geschossen wenn man
es uns befohlen hätte dass uns das
erspart geblieben ist das ist ein glück
und eine gnade der geschichte
ihnen allen danke ich für ihre guten
worte und ihnen liebe zuschauer für ihr
interesse
bleiben sie uns treu
[Musik]